uh I am San Francisco district attorney
Brooke Jenkins
and I want to start by first sending our
well wishes to Mr Pelosi once again we
are truly praying for a speedy recovery
on his part
I want to also start by thanking the San
Francisco police department for their
immediate and Swift investigation of
this case
I am here today to formally announce
charges against Mr David depap in
connection with the violent attack on Mr
Pelosi
the charges that we are filing today
include attempted murder residential
burglary assault with a deadly weapon
elder abuse false imprisonment of an
elder as well as threats to a public
official and their family
these charges are based on the following
facts many of which are contained in the
federal affidavit that was filed today
as well as will be contained in the
motion to detain Mr depap that we file
tomorrow
Mr depap specifically targeted the
Pelosi home to confront speaker Pelosi
forced his way into the home through a
rear glass door by breaking that glass
the defendant made his way upstairs to
the second floor of the home locating Mr
Pelosi in his bed sleeping
he woke him up confronting him about the
whereabouts of speaker Pelosi
Mr Pelosi who was sleeping
was wearing a loose-fitting pajama shirt
and boxer shorts
he was forced to get out of bed and at
some point during that encounter Mr
Pelosi attempted to access the elevator
in the home which has a phone
the defendant then blocked Mr Pelosi's
access to that elevator
it was at some point after that Mr
Pelosi asked to go to the bathroom
which is where he was able to call 9-1-1
from his cell phone
the defendant realizing that Mr Pelosi
had called 9-1-1 took Mr Pelosi
downstairs near the front door of the
residence
two police officers arrived at the front
door
two minutes after that 9-1-1 call
when that door was opened the defendant
was holding his hammer which Mr Pelosi
appeared to be attempting to control by
holding a portion of that hammer
the defendant then pulled the hammer
away from Mr Pelosi and violently struck
him in the top of his head
the police then immediately apprehended
the defendant
what we also have learned is that the
defendant brought to the location of the
Pelosi residents a second Hammer as well
as zip ties rope and a roll of tape
what is clear based on the evidence that
we have thus far is that this house and
the speaker herself were specifically
targets of the defendant
as for next steps
the defendant is expected to be
arraigned tomorrow afternoon my office
will be filing a motion to detain him
without bail and that is based on what
is obvious and severe Public Safety
risks that the defendant poses to San
Francisco as well as the outer community
violence has no place in this city and
we will work vigorously to hold the
defendant accountable
one last thing that I want to say today
is that as leaders and as Citizens
it is incumbent upon us all
to watch the words that we say and to
turn down the volume of our political
rhetoric
we should be able to all engage
in Passionate political discourse but
still remain respectful of one another
violence certainly has no place in San
Francisco or in politics thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else